hey allows happen recently so I think we
need to talk but when I say we need to
talk I don't necessarily mean me in you
I mean humankind needs to start using
their words how am I gonna explain this
I feel like in this day and age our
generation has lost the arts of
communication the basic thing that sets
us apart from animals and makes us these
fantastic intelligent beings we can't
communicate what do I mean by this
because obviously I'm an idiot
everyone's talking every day most people
talk too much and don't listen enough we
hear that a lot yes I will agree with
that people do talk a lot about things
that don't matter or about things they
think matters but in the long run will
not help themselves all of humankind as
a whole I feel like in this Western
culture this generation is so worried
about the way that we're being perceived
by others we live in a world of the
internet and social media where
everything we do takes us a little bit
longer we have character limits the
liking system on Facebook we have
filters on Instagram and snapchat we
don't just say what we want from the
heart anymore we think about it
meticulously and wonder what will get us
the most attention on these different
social media platforms what time should
we be putting our thoughts out there for
them to see that and receive it in a
good manner we're not simply
communicating we are kind of turning
this into an odd social business model
would it be called that nowadays we have
certain social pressures that we feel
that we need to abide by we want to make
sure that we get likes whenever we put
up
new facebook profile picture we want to
make sure that if we make a tweet about
something controversial that perhaps the
majority of people will agree so we'll
check the hashtag first we don't speak
from ourselves anymore because we're
scared I mean want to be liked by people
we want to be perceived as a good person
by these social standards that are given
to us by society and through the
internet and it's not just the Internet
it's the media as well we're constantly
told how we should look how we should
act watch of films see the magazines on
the shelves look at some adverts or
billboards and you're constantly
reminded this is how you're supposed to
look this is what you're supposed to do
to achieve this look everything is very
shallow so it's no wonder why we've
forgotten to simply communicate and just
talk about how we feel we're so worried
about our outer shell and how people
will look at us and what they will judge
us by on the outside that we've
forgotten how to verbalize what's
actually going on on the inside this is
so delicate and this isn't just about
physical image either this is also about
what we're doing with our lives what we
choose to do with our lives how we
choose to live our lives
it's the places that we go the foods
that we eat are you vegan are you not do
you love bacon or do you love soy milk
it's all something that we're constantly
thinking about and how we want to be
perceived by the world job role what do
you want to do for a job is it something
that you actually love or are you just
in a certain trouble because it sounds
good are you a manager of a company are
you working in advertising or are you
simply selling ice cream because one
might make you happier than the other
however one definitely sounds better to
the public and by the way I'm talking
about being a manager or working in
advertising sounds better than selling
ice cream although you know free ice
cream you can't
are you a that just seems that most
things we do nowadays are to impress
other people it's not to make ourselves
happy and we're constantly worried about
how we're being perceived and we don't
even think about what's going on inside
or we do but we keep it in because it's
no one's place or it's going to tarnish
this wonderful image of ourselves that
we have spent years and years and years
perfecting online and offline we are
masters at explaining what our passions
are what we do for fun where we like to
go what we like to eat what we are doing
as a job or what we want to be doing as
a job but as soon as someone asked you
the simple question of how are you
feeling are you okay with this something
more meaningful than just what are you
doing or how would you look or what is
your title things start to get a little
bit more scary and we start to back away
because we're not used to that anymore
we're not used to expressing the actual
feelings that make us human that make us
amazing and if we can't express our true
selves to others then how are we
supposed to know what is real how are we
supposed to know that the people that
hang around us don't just hang around us
because of our social status or the way
that we look or the way that we act or
the job that we have or the money that
we're getting how are we supposed to
know that people actually like us for
who we are for what's going on inside
and not only other people but how are we
supposed to influence the world or
really think about world issues if we're
just focusing on the outer shell of
every single situation that is going on
we're stuck in a world that is ruled by
such a shallow mindset even big worldly
matters really important issues are
being kind of brushed under the rug and
seen as entertainment value because
everything's entertainment value
nowadays we don't actually talk about
real things because that's boring we
want to know the dirt we want to know
the drama we want to see the banter we
wants it to be entertainment
for ourselves we don't wanna know the
realism behind the real issues that lie
underneath or could perhaps lie
underneath Oh am I even making sense I
don't know nothing seems personal
anymore because everyone is so worried
about tarnishing their the wonderful
image that they have made for themselves
that they've kind of forgotten who they
truly are and how they truly feel and
that no you're not a robot you might be
working towards your career you might be
working towards looking perfect being
perfect being the entertainment that you
want everyone has to see but you're not
no one is and you need to start
realizing that about yourself and also
realize that about other people and
other situations as well it's not always
a game and a joke and fun and happy
things are real things are serious and
things can get bad and that's okay I
love the Internet
I love media but at the same time I feel
like it it's really kind of tore us
apart a little bit we don't know how to
be real people anymore we're so used to
worrying about putting ourselves out in
such a robotic way that we can't simply
just be we can't simply get deep and
real with people or other matters
everything is entertainment
everything things that shouldn't be
entertainment are entertainment
we'll make a meme of it we'll make it
funny YouTube video we'll make a parody
song sometimes it's just not needed
we'll end up ruining ourselves we'll
just take the piss out of our own
humankind we will become the joke when
we only show a fake outset of ourselves
nothing is real nothing you live for is
real no when you talk to is real and no
decisions you make have any real
repercussions no no no no that's a lie
they do and you're just not thinking
about it I'm sorry this got pretty
emotional just really wanted to talk
about it let's feel like people nowadays
don't know how to communicate their
feelings they don't know how to be
themselves they don't know how to take
other people seriously and I I just find
that really sad
that people can't open up anymore and
they have to hide behind entertainment
value behind drama behind something else
because it's too scary to just literally
dig inside take it out and give it to
someone else
we need to learn how to do that again or
we are literally going to turn into one
big society of jokes
it's just how I feel and I just knew
skills my chest so thank you for
listening I hope this made sense if you
have any comments on this please leave a
comment in the section the section of
comments below let's converse let's talk
let's talk yes a little ease day or
evening bye I can't we communicate
anymore oh my god
you